after weeks of rainfall Monrovia --nz
awoke to sunny skies on Election Day
lines at polling stations along with the
country's economy in dire straits and an
80% jobless rate amongst youth people
say they're ready for change one
candidate has emerged as a surprising
frontrunner over the last few weeks
Alexander Cummings a political newcomer
is a former top manager at coca-cola we
can and will good economy will creat
jobs will work on and fix infrastructure
may Liberia and we can change our
country we deserve a better like urea
and that's what we're committing to
doing for our people the campaign has
been marked by frequent personal verbal
attacks among the 20 candidates some
election observers have expressed
concern that tension could escalate it's
been 13 years since the end of Liberia's
civil war that claimed more than a
quarter of a million lives and the
country is still struggling to recover
but while emotions at the polls remain
high most voters seem optimistic that
the election results will be recognized
by everyone the youth if anything goes
wrong we should have said the result
election observers say they're satisfied
with the voting process the European
Union has sent more than 80 of its staff
to monitor proceedings none of them has
registered any gray voting
irregularities so far we have had some
concern about the fact that all the
districts will be covered because we
have had some concerns about the rainy
periods if it's possible to have all the
materials in all the different polling
station and for the moment we have the
information that everything went right
power outages haven't stopped Liberians
from lining up at the polls either
today's their day that's the word on the
street and since it looks like a close
race they're convinced every vote counts